emmanuel macron se rendra ce matin au
mont valérien un mémorial de la france
combattante dans les hauts-de-seine il
doit participer à la commémoration de
l'appel du 18 juin 1940 il prendra
ensuite la direction de londres le
président va assister au 80e
anniversaire de l'appel du 18 juin lancé
par le général de gaulle à cette
occasion à la statue de winston
churchill sort de sa boîte métallique
rappel avait été installé pour la
préserver des récentes manifestations
on le rappelle c'est la première fois
que le président français effectue un
déplacement hors de france depuis le
début du confinement
on en parlera en direct avec christophe
baudot et les anciens présidents des
jeunes gaullistes hauteur de la
démocratie à l'épreuve de l'intégration
européenne
bonjour marty d'âtre en direct avec nous
alors l'appel du 18 juin un moment
historique qui marque les esprits
91 ans après oui alors en effet je crois
que ce qu'il faut retenir de la paix le
18 juin 81 ans après c'est deux choses
d'abord c'est une
c'est un cri de révolte révolte contre
l'esprit du temps à l'époque l'esprit du
temps et on verra revenir cet esprit
plus tard cette l'esprit d'abandon
l'esprit de renoncement c'est monique en
quelque sorte qui incarne ça l'esprit du
temps qui a conduit à la débâcle à la
débâcle militaire qui était précédé
d'une débâcle morale intellectuelle
psychologique politique bien dénoncer à
la fois par bernanos ou par de gaulle
lui-même et marc bloch l'écrivain marc
bloch dont l'étrange défaite
et puis c'est aussi d'abord un espoir à
un espoir contre tout contre une
évidence devant lui devant nous qui
allons les français aient lieu les
européens de l'époque était
l'assujettissement la soumission
l'asservissement la défaite et je
rappelle que dans cet espoir dans cette
dans cet esprit optimiste de gaulle
était très très seul
évidemment il était très solitaire avec
churchill au fond qui était très seul
aussi l'un sans l'autre
jamais peut-être il n'y aurait eu ni
l'épopée gaulliste ni la libération en
1945 puisque autour d'eux que ce soit
sortie dans son gouvernement avec son
propre mini affaires étrangères halifax
où que ce soit de gaulle évidemment avec
les autorités françaises mais aussi
roosevelt et d'autres étaient
foncièrement pessimiste et était dans
une logique de deux défaites et ce cri
de 1940 est en ce sens un cri
métaphysique c'est à dire un cri de
révolte
de l'esprit qui ne veut pas se soumettre
et de cette civilisation française et
européenne qui dit nous ne nous
soumettrons pas monsieur est ce que
finalement tout le monde ne se dit pas
ne se dispute pas un peu l'héritage du
général
alors dès le lendemain de sa disparition
le 9 270 les commentateurs ont
évidemment évoqué ça que restera-t-il du
gaullisme après de gaulle c'est une
éternelle question comme pour toutes les
les
tous les grands hommes qui laissent
derrière eux une doctrine ce qu'on peut
appeler une doctrine c'est à dire un
ensemble de principes et de valeurs il
ne s'agit pas d'une idéologie et bien
naturellement il ya beaucoup de gens qui
se sont réclamés que se réclament encore
de de gaulle le choix personne ne doit
ou ne peut être admis à décerner des
brevets de gaullisme et que en tout état
de cause c'est une bonne chose que de
gaulle soit aujourd'hui un modèle y
compris pour des gens qui l'ont combattu
ou qui ôte son font partie de familles
politiques qui l'ont combattu
encore faut-il pas ce qu'il faut pas
être naïf a évidemment encore faut-il
que cette cette adhésion à l'homme du 18
juin ne soit pas qu'une adhésion de
façade et une adhésion superficielle or
c'est souvent le cas parce que qu'est-ce
que c'est que le gaullisme mais c'est
d'abord la souveraineté est la
souveraineté individuelle n'oubliez pas
cette phrase qui est gravé dans le
marbre à colombes et au pied d'al delà
de la croix de lorraine
il n'est qu'une seule querelle qui
vaille celle de l'homme et cette
souveraineté se décliner ce souverain
pcc la souveraineté nationale c'est la
souveraineté populaire
ça veut dire aussi l'association étroite
par exemple des travailleurs au capital
de leur entreprise le dépassement de la
division capital travail à travers la
participation et l'intéressement 7
grands
réforme qui n'a jamais pu être menée
jusqu'au bout c'est aussi la
décentralisation très poussé aujourd'hui
faudrait donner davantage de pouvoir de
responsabilité au maire enfin voilà
derrière cette idée du gaullisme il y a
beaucoup de principes beaucoup de valeur
que ceux qui se réclament du gaullisme
seraient bien tentés de dont il serait
bien tenté de s'inspirer dans l'action
pour aujourd'hui beaucoup d'avoir
répondu à nos questions rappelle que
vous êtes ancien président des jeunes
gaullistes hauteur de la démocratie à
l'épreuve de l'intégration européenne
bercy